welcome to new stars live thank you guys
so much for being here my name is phil
molina I kind of like started this thing
and I'm really excited to to get to see
where it's gotten at this point is just
so amazing to have you guys here I could
not have done it without the help of
Erik Bosse my friend Sam basher and then
I you might know him from smashing
smashing related items matt is one of
the biggest Marvel fans I know super
excited to have him here but also thank
you guys so much for being thank you
very much thank you so much to the El
Capitan for hosting our screening let's
give it up for them amazing experience
you guys all got to see that that's my
favorite way to watch it fire real quick
before we get started I just gotta plug
our new podcast it's called inside
Marvel make sure to subscribe to that if
you want any of our theories breakdowns
that we do also maybe a potential new
upcoming Marvel related show all of that
comes out first on the podcast and then
finally about podcast we cannot have
done all these podcast things that we're
doing or this event without Himalaya
Media Kilauea has been helping us a lot
so Hulya has been helping out in the
rosters for a while since we launched
our first podcast earlier this year and
then in June we're gonna launch
something hey I know what it is but I'll
just say apparently it says something
really special so - it's a baby alright
but what the well this part actually I
tell you about new rock stars Plus is
going to be a premium podcast
subscription on Himalayas platform
that's going to include completely add
free versions of everything you guys
find now on the new rock stars podcast
plus some podcast shows that we're
making exclusively only for premium
subscribers if you guys want more
information about that we are probably
gonna have a link in the description or
something I'm looking at the one person
that knows and he was drinking
in that moment but guys what you guys
think of avengers endgame a complex wave
of emotion just bled from the eyes all
right we just saw it got out of the
movie first off before I asked for
official first reactions I want to know
first emotional reaction that you had
walking out show it to me super
confusing way to feel about this whole
thing Eric would you would you think
just coming out of it just like
emotionally I would supposed your
reaction so much movie I'm glad that
Marvel did it this way because I would
watch eight hours of Marvel if I could
it's the place I will be able to see but
I don't want any other studio to copy
this model because I think Marvel is the
one a group of geniuses who figured out
how to pull this off over eleven years
of films
22:23 now films now looking over 23 they
made this climactic ending that
connected back to the previous films and
so many interesting ways
spoiler oh yes watched Avengers endgame
in the world you're gonna get I think in
any third act or any finale you've
wanted to call back and connect to
everything that we've seen before so
that pretty much is just made up of
callbacks and recycled but in a good way
surprising bits of dialogue that pays
off things we saw earlier and I feel
like the entire endgame film was that
about like a fireworks finale you know
after the boring 45 minutes a good
conclusion both emotional emotionally
speaking and like just the real ride
yeah Sam Matt alright this I gotta say
I'm lucky enough to be able to see this
twice and told cried both times screamed
both times it was like a rollercoaster
but I was sitting still so that was
definitely not fun for anyone around
crying so of a genuinely cried so much
and didn't drink any water beforehand
that I felt the hydrated out it's good
it's all good because this was something
that hasn't been pull off before it's
something special for everybody here
everyone around the world that is
invested their time and money and energy
into these movies and TV shows and
properties they didn't just like pull it
off they did that plus a thousand plus
$3,000 it's crazy because like you guys
like predicted a good amount of stuff
but that didn't change the fact that
this was still a surprise a thrill ride
and the journey to get to where like the
endings that you predicted was still a
treasure and I can't wait to watch it 30
more times in theaters please come with
me it's exhausting I mean the coaster is
100 percent right like I went in luckily
I went social media blackout for three
days beforehand I was like too many
spoilers read at Twitter everything's
got spoilers I went in completely blind
I saw the first trailer and I was on
that ride with every peak and every bell
it was insane I was physically exhausted
afterwards not too much because I went
home had dinner came back and saw it
again tomorrow and it was a lot but it
was just it's a lot it's so much movie
like you said it really is and there's
no real boring parts like there's
everything didn't even made me care
about Thor - no one can do that
miracles can happen yeah I felt that
same thing about this concept of it felt
like more than a movie and I've only had
that a few times I came to in my life as
a phone call
whether or not you liked it or hate it I
had that with interstellar well I was
like this was a class I could call the
class sums up that I had a bit with
Blade Runner 49 20 49 and then this
basically where I don't have you guys
felt this but especially once we hit the
credits and you're seeing these things I
was like this feels like the last movie
ever made
the boarding up the Arklay yeah alright
so I want to hear now let's go you guys
know our our thing we get pretty deep in
our in our dives and we're gonna get
pretty analytical so up front we're just
gonna keep a light for a moment here I
just want to hear like just what's your
favorite moment just favorite moment
from the movie honestly the they were
able to keep so much stuff hidden you
know like there it's it's so impressive
the like not only like Disney fully
trust what they're gonna do right it
doesn't matter like the Marvel stamp on
it they can do whatever they want but
when it came to Hulk overall was ice
it's my favorite use of that character
and it's mainly because of Mark
Ruffalo's like his mannerisms and his
comedy but also you get just a little
bit of physical comedy with him being a
little bit bumbly but also he's cool
like I want more of this character I
want a Disney Plus show of this
character please thank you happy oh yeah
the whole time I leak ride at Avengers
Assemble I was I was just blubbering in
the thing that was my moment that is
what have we been waiting for they'd
never done it they've never said it it's
a callback but it's also still a reveal
it was perfect it was exactly what I
wanted which is why I had to see it
again because I was like I was so
overwhelmed with emotion I missed most
of the battle things happening that's
crazy but it that was my favorite moment
hands-down yeah for me it was that for
which is the truth or in my mind all of
the all these years I thought okay if I
really just start hitting the gym maybe
I can make in cosplay as Chris Hemsworth
like Eric and I have known each other
for for 35 years but the moment you said
that fat Thor was your like favorite I
was like of course because you have been
compared to Chris Hemsworth if he wasn't
so you know I mean I preferred that that
Pratt let me down when he left hold up
as star-lord I was just waiting for him
to bulk back out I mean it felt like
when you know young girls were going to
see Wonder Woman and finally they had to
hear on screen
for me it's up for me I mean guys it's
it's I am Iron Man because I kicked off
the whole dang thing right 65 years ago
that that just hearing that again and it
kind of meaning something else this time
but man like I also a glee club cried
I'm like trying not to actually revisit
those emotions today we'll do it here
now but I'm actually curious what you
guys thought the the kind of most epic
moment was wouldn't stick with that so
I'm gonna give you a list and then we're
gonna do this one by round of applause
you guys ready all right so uh these are
all so dang good all right when Captain
America says hail Hydra oh man these are
Oh God okay these are all cap cap
finally saying Avengers Assemble
yeah
[Applause]
camera goes flying through the air cap
wields me on your thank you so much - um
you're cool all right sounds like that
was the most epic moment movie in a way
we're gonna get to protecting someone in
a little bit all right so now I want to
go into that's kind of like these like
epic moments right
what moments when like BAM and hit you
in the fields with when this flickered
off probably for me but I'm sorry just
like it wasn't a fade it was just like
your phone dying it felt so real didn't
feel too cinematic or over-the-top it
just felt like when you do lose someone
that is kind of how it goes and it and
it felt like losing a friend who we've
been growing up with you know honestly
like it's there are the bigger moments
but this like the moment that really got
me was when Tony accidentally discovers
time travel and he sits down and he's
can't believe what he just discovered
like this is the linchpin of saving the
entire universe and of course he curses
his daughter here's a headache and she's
perfect she's such such a perfect foil
for him in this movie but that reaction
of him like gasping covering his mouth
and realizing the implications of what
he just created it's amazing it's such a
good moment what at me in the feels I
mean when Thorne his buddies get
trash-talked in fortnight my play yeah
time travel enough for tonight trash
talk I never said ha no I mean it's a
simple form a hundred percent the fact
always been waiting so long he didn't
say it in any of the Avenger movies
they're all together for the very first
time it got me it just got why why do
you think what just is I mean I've been
a comic book fan my entire life and like
the fact that we've never had this
massive battle fight scene like a splash
page like a huge thing we've never
really
had that this is the first time they
were getting it and I was just
overwhelmed with emotion
it was insane it was just so it was just
heartwarming and gave me hope about
cinema gave me hope about pop culture
and geek culture was amazing it was the
coolest thing ever
yeah man I like I just have to be honest
with you guys there is a at one point
not long ago I lost somebody and when
pepper says it's it's okay we're okay
you can rest now I said those exact
words I was like holy crap yeah that is
like what this whole thing has been
about
all right and I was just so like proud
of them and I was so proud of him that
moment I still gets me how about biggest
surprises we did predict a lot and yet
the movie felt completely surprising
things that were totally unexpected
first 40 minutes the first 20 minutes I
mean I have like three knows yeah three
top favorite moments in a movie theater
one of them is the snap at the end of
infinity war one of them is the last
Twilight movie come on well I mean I've
never been a Twilight fan I don't care I
thought we were talking to only MCU and
nothing they went through and killed
everybody it was like a big deal that
was a huge moment and then this one were
the first 20 minutes of a movie where
all the marketing has been about like
we're gonna get the anos guys we're
gonna get him and the first 20 minutes
the cop is dead chop his head off I was
like and it was insane it was such a
cool moment and hearing the audible
gasps at five years later I was like
what are we gonna do is it just a relief
group for another two and a half hours
gonna be it was insane yeah I think the
moment I think my brain melted when
Spiderman is carrying an Infinity
Gauntlet riding a Pegasus man Thor's
hammer through a space battle against
like an evil God and I'm like yeah I
could really see that one coming
yeah that felt like truly like Patton
Oswalt's like spider-man's right for me
the biggest surprise is how conclusive
this movie was because Marvel's whole
business models what's coming next post
credit scene we've got a second post
credit scene this has had nothing we
just had you know be roots stayed
through the end of the credits you're a
sound of tony hammer in its armor in the
cave and just to bring you back to where
it all started
it felt like this is just a goodbye and
that's okay we can let go we'll make
like weeks where it's going next enough
like evidence throughout the movie of
some teases to come really but this
isn't about like turning the page it's
about closing the book and to me that's
what was most the end of a trade
paperback at the end of a trade
paperback that's not the end these
characters aren't all gonna disappear
and then we can start the next trade
paperback that's interesting about that
to me is that those often n is so epic
and then there's like a little like side
story that you get like one one is
shorter and that feels like spider-man
far from home it's gonna be that yeah
you could you guys see that that came by
he said that's the end of the vlog we're
gonna get into later when that movie
takes place we had some questions yeah
to make confusing when we were talking
about infinity war we we thought this is
previously previously on your rock stars
infinity war the protagonist movie is
Thanos right yeah this has the clear
goal he's the one that has to make a
sacrifice and he's the one that achieves
his goal at the end who wasn't in this
movie for you guys like who do you feel
had to learn or change in some ways who
had that like that that clear that clear
goal Tony I'd say I think it's Tony
through and through because it kind of
brings it all back around like when
you're saying when he died it's about
him resting and it's the fact that he
can't is that he tried to he tried to
prepare us and it backfired bad and
that's his fall and that's the avengers
fault but he wasn't wrong and like and
it's him come to terms with okay i can't
do it that way but i still can't stop
how much i like how much i care and how
much i'm will help far I'm willing to go
to protect the earth and that you
finally can reach that ending and how
far he's willing to push himself
especially when it comes back to the
Avengers first movie where he talks
about
the wire or laying down on the wire for
his fellow man and it's like he chose to
cut the wire at the end of the day and
it's alright to lay down on the wire and
it's I truly feel like it's his movie
but caps like literally right there like
really made like a hand a head the only
reason with you I say Tony is because of
that two things the thing you were
saying about him finally being able to
rest right I if you remember the scene
with the scene earlier with pepper I he
he was told like when he says oh maybe I
just shouldn't bring it up but I saw
time travel and she's like you won't be
able to rest if you do that right and
then later he is finally able to rest
but also I feel like it was really
telling when he went and spoke with his
father Howard Stark and his father talks
about that concept of I can you like
what what about you putting the greater
good above sorry yeah even though it is
technically you know for noble reasons
his family right he wants to like keep
his family safe he still hit like that
is still technically selfish and in the
greater terms and so you start when he
sacrifices himself to me a time I don't
know if you guys feel like it's more
caps movie I mean I think it's the two
of them like I I went into this movie
all new watching the first trailer and
like all of our geek brains what I do is
when I see a trailer I start to piece
the movie together in my head and that
moment that they have in the trailer is
like do you trust me and he's like of
course I trust you and I was like that
moment didn't feel earned ivory watched
all the movies recently as I'm sure
everybody did it was like there are so
many better bromances and relationships
you've got Captain Bucky you've got
Rhodey and Tony you've got all these
characters and I was like if we're gonna
get this like cap and Tony relationship
I feel like it's not earned they did it
in this movie they made me believe that
the two of these guys are co-chair of
the Avengers and these guys are the
founding members and they're doing a
thing and by the end of the movie the
fact that the two of them had their
essentially rest is is it they were the
both the main protagonists and maybe a
little bit of nebula I think that she
had a little bit of an art a little bit
of a journey but beyond that I think it
was a hundred percent of two of them cuz
doors not gonna Cruces sticking around
yeah let's see if it's not the two of
them this is truly the ensemble movie
that I think the original Avengers was
they made things to protagonist out of
necessity because they had some idea but
here they you know they thin the herd
and they were able to get back to the
original crew and make kind of what was
essentially like an oceans
inception style heist movie where
everyone is kind of working together
though would happen then there's an
argument to be made that it was the core
Avengers movie right because then was
given an arc and they weren't previously
done that didn't happen before alright I
want to kind of brainstorm here for a
second and think about something what
does it mean not like let's just talk
about what the world is like now like
now let's skip to you know really really
foggy a week now yeah but like a week
after all this like our people that were
not dusted now they're back and now for
some of them it's like what do you mean
you got remarried I've been gone for
five minutes like us from their from
their shame what are some things you
like five minutes it felt like instant
and Peter said like I kind of woke up I
was dusty anymore and dr. strange showed
up and dragged me into a big battle yeah
yeah it's it's odd because I want to
know how many of those kids in that high
school at the end or some of them have
graduated and now they got to go to
school with the seventh graders right I
was wondering is that college actually
and maybe like NetID now in college also
did five years pass Burnette me on me
I'm gonna guess that when it comes to
those cast members like MJ flash Ned
Peter they got dusted and we move on
from there and kind of like figure out
what most for it but also like think
about like so you own a house you're
gone you come back who's there who's in
your home now what happened to your car
what happens to your money is your bank
still like does that mean anything
what like tends to be banquet chases
your money my
where there's no government half the
government is covered in it for five
years
banks anybody like all that stuff is
gone there's a half the police force is
gone half of everybody's there are
raccoons everything yeah it's it's an
odd world that we didn't really just see
the aftermath of I'm I'm interested to
see I mean one of the theories may we'll
get into this later of like what
universe even the smart mind far from
home could take place in is it in one of
these alternate multiverse timelines
that was set up
branched off from the main timeline
where you know because there's one
timeline where Thanos basically ended in
zipped off to the free future I guess
his conquest is over and now we're just
like living in this world where no snap
ever had
well we have so much to break down
because when he talks to the ancient one
she says that if the the tide death
stones get out of place then there's new
branches if they don't remember the
branch kind of like comes back so it's
almost like it's not a new branch it is
very good everybody puts everything back
including like the owner right but I
mean Thanos and the entirety of his
cause of his people are gone they're not
coming back he disappeared with the
space dog he's off somewhere all kinds
of Disney Plus adventures yeah what I
got from it was that there are gonna be
branches because the fact that you move
back in time at all like that
immediately makes another branch so you
have to move with that you have to give
the deal with that but mitigating the
like the offshoots when it comes to like
put everything back don't make any big
changes I think it's just there's random
offshoots now where the whole talk to
Tilda Swinton one sorry it's gonna so
then specifically is the MCU now five
years in the future they do drive a
concept Audie card I don't know if you
saw that when they they go to Tony's
cabin that's a future car and here's to
finally win the future to 2024 got this
car audio and brought it back but yeah
are these movies suddenly now five years
ahead of us I think so and I think that
you know if agents of shield is staying
within Canon it's I would believe that
they would play with the five years cuz
if there's one thing you can stretch on
an ABC show for forever it's like loss
like oh man sucks all the heroes are
gone we got to do everything for them
you know what I mean like that's easy to
do a scene you think you think agents
shield might do at least one season
without any heroes out there and yeah
it's just gonna be them it's so simple
because they're not gonna get them
anyway so it's so easy to make are we
gonna make up for it and also you have
like a lot of like eat the playground
kind of bigger now because if you do
move forward like what up the shang-chi
movie that's coming out took place in
between the both snaps and so he is like
a necessity that was born out of a
really desperate time and now it's
moving forward from there you could you
can kind of play around with where
movies start happening in the future
which i think is pretty cool what about
some ramifications of some of this
time-travel I just hide your think that
cap is on their side now I just well at
least at this moment for a couple years
they're like
you legit in that timeline yeah they're
probably confused yeah records like this
know what my only thing is maybe that
cap you know after he goes back he
returns to the elevator and does the
fight scene so since Santos went to the
future and was killed in the future then
a lot of the events in the MCU happened
at like since the 2012 issue right a lot
of the movies that we saw since then
were about power the Power Stone and and
and there's Anthony stones do none of
those happen no they they what happened
happened I think somewhere when Hulk
Banner started yelling at everyone how
physics works he explained how the rules
of this time-travel work I think I'm
good anything rotten re-watch that a
couple times to figure out exactly what
the rules are but my takeaway from that
is that what happened happened and if
changes happen it causes new timelines
to branch off it does not ripple effect
or erase anything it's dark world still
happen sorry man
both of the Guardians movies still
happen unfortunately that Gomorrah is
still dead so good question right there
right so what what deaths are permanent
then is is Loki dead well actually let's
do lucky on one side he's Black Widow
dead yes so we said what little did you
guys think like what is dead well we
didn't see the final mission but I mean
we'll we don't know what red skulls
return policy is but she might still be
alive
but vision 100% dead
no he's computer downloaded he's fine so
there is that moment with Sheree right
where she sees him coming she does one
last thing it does seem like she could
have downloaded him okay so low key
though is low key out there now messing
around I guess ventures well you do this
red and he's out there but more
happening at the same time in multiple
parallel realities guys give me a dry
erase board draw multiple routes for me
or you shove a pencil always explains it
mobius strip yeah both alive in debt he
died in the events of the first avenger
or Avengers infinity war but then in
this new timeline that branched off he
grabbed the tesseract and zipped out of
there and that's what the Disney Plus
series both happened like in the main
storyline moving forward he's gonzo he's
dead is that in that storyline there's
gonna be an alternate timeline in which
he is alive Tony's alive so so you're
saying in one of these alternate
timelines there could be a fat Loki
along with the moai
we got an audience question here and
it's kind of around some of the stuff
they're talking abouts related to Red
Skull Tommy who do you got thanks
Phillip what is your name Amanda Amanda
we have Amanda here and was your
question what do you think Captain
America did to get back the stones to
Vermeer and morad oh yeah so if we
didn't pick her up did cap basically got
a deal or Red Skull to get that stone
back yeah that's my part of that
question noted cap do yeah that would be
a really good side story just like you
know like on the way to Thor's hammer
when you have that short story it's like
wow on the way back to deliver all the
Infinity stones we'll put Thor's hammer
back like that's interesting cuz maybe
he did have to talk to him maybe he just
needed like Hawk in a lake and then he
could kind of move on yeah but I there's
something interesting there but I just
don't think we have enough time in any
properties to deal with the form your
story with more egg it's like kind of
like a safe you can kind of put it back
or as star-lords knocked out he can kind
of just like put in his hand and get out
of that smelling salts cuz they gave him
a concussion to get him out of there for
me or though that's interesting I don't
know if there's quite an answer did cap
shove the ether back into Natalie
Portman
back as a rock and it's supposed to be
like syrup and so he must've just like
tell me we're good you can let her sit
down how about the movie then as this
cap of the infinity saga what do you
guys think the whole frickin saga was
about what are these arcs and I kind of
throw out there real quick I feel like
you know Ironman it surprisingly Hawkeye
I really underlined this idea of finding
your family right and and what you are
like without your family and what you
are with it and and kind of sacrificing
yourself for your family or what you
become without them and whatnot I think
there's something there but what do you
guys think what is this well what do we
just spend our lives on produce a
longtime friendship friendship I got to
meet all you guys we're good friends the
Infinity stones were us oh they're
inside you yeah I mean I love you I know
your points pretty on point and when it
comes to friendship and building
families because you're able to see
these people that are pretty just
separate and they're isolated and they
and they have their little places in the
world but they want more they want to
contribute and they want to make a
difference and the best way you can do
that way is when you can do it together
and all and yeah that's basically when
it you wind it down it comes to that but
hot dang they did a good job with these
movies huh gang yeah it's like this is
all bit about connection I think the
Marvel comics are all about connection
the interconnectivity of these worlds in
the fact that each of these characters
are larger than some of their parts
whereas I think if you read DC Comics
some other brands of comics is about
like that bracket individualism and how
is this character different in his or
her point of view in Marvel it's like
they're all friends in spider-man's
gonna hang out with daredevil in this
comic it's great it's better because
they're friends now so the fact that the
end of this movie featured Tony Stark
really the hero of this overall
franchise bringing the entire family
back together so that they can all be
friends and a Giants team together
it felt like the pain off that
connection and that once you do that if
you can bring people together that's you
can let go I mean it's an a logistic
really like it's the Infinity stones all
coming together from various corners of
the universe into one thing just like
how all of these different characters
came together to form the MCU right it's
exactly what it is like each of these
different stones represented a different
aspect of the Marvel Universe magic
space wizardry regular wizardry Spade
let's just dunk all the different things
just like dudes in the military like all
this different stuff all came together
and that's exactly what the MCU was it
really is like it tied it all together
it's interesting they say was right
because they come on it kind of feels
like that it does I just where do you go
from here like what like you know I love
that it's like hey Tony we're gonna be
okay he was like yeah right there never
is gonna be another threat on the earth
you're right you can totally die we're
good forever yeah but if any family on
earth is like probably okay it's that
family there's like billionaire family
with nanotech doxa burgers but where
it's going actually is actually where I
want to go next
let's talk I mean we this is our bread
and butter gyro sucks theories right so
where is this all headed so the first
one I want to talk about kind of a big
deal
Captain America hands his shield to Sam
not Bucky who a lot of people have been
expecting that and you if you read the
comics you kind of like well like yeah
you know probably good about luck either
times where it's gone Sam but so my
question is are do you guys think that
we're about to see a bunch of movies
Captain America movies starring old man
Captain America
throwing shoes Frederickson from no is
Sam about to be our news Captain America
and I I like Sam being Captain America
Sam t-thank you know but also doesn't it
kind of make more sense to set Bucky
Bucky's been on world terrorist like
four times his face has been plastered
all over like we gotta find this guy
like they recruited like teachers to
find him like they are like he wanted
everyone to look for him and like he
just got out of therapy and then he died
and now he's back it's been like hours
since he got out of therapy and got they
okay
barely and like so it's like maybe he
shouldn't represent what America is he
sounds exactly I was I was okay with it
I really love the idea of Bucky getting
it but I also in the comics and correct
me if I'm wrong I'm pretty sure the
reason why Sam plays cap is because they
establish that his dad was actually in
the Super Soldier program so he has a
little bit of the Super Soldier blood in
it like Oh which makes sense because
it's like otherwise Sam's just a dude
with a really cool backpack like that's
cool he's got a backpack and he can
throw a shield like that's not gonna
stop a bullet like it's fine I would
love and I hope this is what they do is
the the Bucky ins in Falcons show it's
just the two of them having a power
struggle it's like I should be capped no
why should be capped and them just
having a really good duo banter I'd love
that I watched the episode of their new
series where they both could handcuff to
the shield I want it I want that to be a
football between them and each episode
they got a trade-off maybe who's more
worthy to marry capsule oh and then at
the end you really spoil errs I guess
but you realize that they represent both
sides of cap and it would be kind of
cool if Steve became like an Oracle type
character like Barbara Gordon and Casey
comics where she was like behind the
scenes huh and so he's tried to figure
out he's a Macbook like an iPad he's
like
downloading toolbars okay we got another
question in the audience Tommy Tommy
where are you hey guys thanks we're back
at the beautiful feet away from Jamie
[Music]
starts what's your week what's your
question assuming that we're moving
forward from the events at the end of
the movie in spider-man homecoming how
does Peter deal expired man apart from
home yeah so far from home sorry yeah so
the question is what's gonna happen with
Peter and spider-man far from home also
kind of part of our question yeah and
when is no bad happening right I mean
fine I think now the now-now right it
makes sense it's a now-now so before
because we just had those five years in
the future maybe in the future a post
everybody being back now are now now
they're no no no yes yes that's
impossible for us to just use your
numbers no we can use yeah but now now
2024 look what year is it they're five
years from infinity war because it was
only twenty two days later in the year
2018 and infinity right so 2023
yeah it seemed because I thought the
math was and this is getting real bad I
thought the math brand for us to figure
this out because when he was tony was
having his monologue on the ship after
they killed him ah I thought he said a
number he said like X many years since
the attack in New York which would have
made it 2019 he said six years from 2012
and 2012 as well
no we didn't address part of my movies
eight years later to like go on that
like you see in the trailer
Aunt May and and with spider-man do it
doing like a charity auction where like
they're giving away money or Happy's
just selling off Tony's old stuff like
his cars and whatnot for money to help
communities and so like I feel like
there's an aspect of like maybe she got
dusted as well I think that's some
article was like oh yes she got this as
well so they come back and they try to
do what they can to help out their
community especially with what Peter can
do and what he represents and trying to
kind of embody what Tony was able to do
for communities around the world so I
think that's where it's gonna be it's
kind of like and maybe he takes a break
over summer because everyone's gonna
have to have a vacation occasionally but
he's needed everywhere he's gotta go
help out in Europe yeah and then airline
tickets are super cheap because no one
wants to be on a flight in case another
deaths happens because then he comes
back as a 16 year old and she's like 22
he's out dating in that older girl yeah
I think it's my I mean I think that
everyone it makes sense that everybody
and his core group got dusted I think
that makes so that they come back
they'll come back and all works out in
the language we're all still 13 years
old I think here's my guess I think
remember he said he for him it was like
five minutes it passed and he was just
like doctor straight said five years
pass so we need to fight remember which
i think is amazing and so on Branford I
character being constantly confused I
think he's gonna be exactly spider-man
we know I love I think they'll just have
Ned constantly like break down in tears
alright it's cool you know we weren't
that tight okay so here's a question um
the sound at the end we touched on it
for a second and Matt already kind of
alluded to this and I it's it's it's my
theory so there wasn't a post-credits
scene in this movie except for you know
all the Marvel movies have post-credit
scenes and this one doesn't so we hear
at the end the sound that we're all
saying oh yeah it's the sound of Iron
Man making this pursue in the 2008 Iron
Man film or is it is it the sound of
potentially the next Iron Man suit
already being made pretty guys think if
they decide to use blunt instruments to
do it maybe I mean he had
use a hammer cuz that's all he had with
a box of scraps you know like
conceivably now young Morgan stark or
Pepper Potts or whoever the next legacy
is Cherie has more nanotech technology
that they can use to build a new Iron
Man see if they're from the Starks right
but it could be someone just out in the
middle of nowhere like a weary will I
really want to yeah yeah I like the idea
of it just kind of being a note of like
this is the sound of the first like
wonder kind of kicking off this whole
universe besides cap in the forties and
but besides Thor being thousands of
years ago oh you know wonky but now I
like that idea that sound kind of being
the end but also marking the future I
feel like I like the idea of someone
backyard building an Ironman like you
don't kill yourself like we saw I like
that idea when it comes to like a like a
younger genius type character like they
want to embody what Tony represented to
them in the sacrifice he made for them
yeah do you guys want another Iron Man
do you guys Wow is there anybody that
does he just like saying oh yeah let's
talk about moving forward in the MCU and
and phase 4 Tommy did you uh did you get
somebody else out there yeah we had
someone here but unfortunately they were
in league with Thanos so when the snap
happened they dust it but I do have
their question are tell me you're
allowed to just ask us a question if
this is your question that's okay what's
next for those crazy kids in the
Avengers who's the what's what villain
do we have to fear next who was gonna be
the next obstacle maybe it's not a
villain I don't know you tell me it
sounds like you have an answer that
you're trying to get to
I don't you wouldn't like it
yes I would ever hear from you guys
who's who's next who's the next obstacle
banister god I came I mean you'd set up
the time travel exit
can you explain who came yeah King is
your classic time-travel villain he
basically instead of a time heist being
a part of the Avengers like we ought to
say the universe he does time heisters
to take things he wants and anyway or
even kidnapped the people he wants to
affect his own future and become king of
whatever he wants to be he can do
whatever in the top there you go exactly
so there's you can get a really long
story out of that like seriously like
what you can kind of get stories that
were like in ancient times or in the
future or you have characters bouncing
around or new teams popping up to kind
of face different versions of him
because that happens a lot in comics you
get business suit variant you get young
him who's actually an Iron Man variant
as iron lad you get older version and
wears all purple there's a lot of
versions in today they like their purple
very old villains so one might have
another one I am I think so I haven't
got the I was fortunate enough to
interview Kevin Feige like right after
he got promoted after he was a VR Ed's
assistant for like 15 years
right after they did Hulk and we were
talking when you're just just gushing
about comic books because back then it
was a weird thing to do as opposed it is
now and he was saying the one thing he
wishes he would be able to do period is
Secret Invasion he would love to be able
to a secret evasion which why I was kind
of let down with Captain Marvel cuz they
kind of just like made the scrolls kind
of weak they were just kind of these
like refugees they weren't things like
badass alien race that I know them as
but I feel like that would be a really
cool way to do that you can definitely
kind of swap out characters and it's
basically invasion of the body snatchers
scrolls came in they could change your
faces and they just started like
plucking up heroes and just changing
them and turning it into like a secret
war essentially not the secret war but a
secret war and I think that would be rad
like you do that over the next 10 movies
and it's like you don't know who's who
you have no idea it's back to like it's
basically clue right like you're trying
to figure out every character you see
you're like wait is this a scroll or is
that new cap or what is going on here
how's that gonna work there's a scroll
out there search we're gonna find that
scroll just because the scroll we saw
the Captain Marvel we're nice peaceful
refugees it doesn't mean that there are
other you know
evil scrolls their various motive
scrolls I I have it as fan theory that I
think there is a scroll somewhere in the
MCU it's so easy just to put him into
this whole time online there is a
character who's a scroll I I would love
to see secret invasion I agree with you
man that would probably my number one
pick but I think like really the
direction they're gonna go is Galactus
Silver Surfer right I mean they just
required that I would be surprised at
the in apart from him I thought we would
see it in a post-credits scene for this
movie I think after forever boom we're
gonna see some kind of hint toward
Galactus Silver Surfer maybe dr. doom
because I think they're most eager to
bring in the Fantastic Four ok so if you
watch the video back my eyes start
exploding when you said knocking and I
was like Secret Wars but the more recent
one where it became it's a story of you
of different realities kind of starting
to die or different universes and they
all get pieced together into one world
called battle world but you could do it
based on what they based it would happen
in this movie with the divergent
timelines we're like basically we start
what if they start making movies where
you get these like side stories of like
oh these are new heroes popping up but
then you start realizing oh they're not
happening in you know the universe where
the rest of our stories are happening at
the same time so all of a sudden they
start getting pieced together by a
villain like Doctor Doom where you get
like the beyond or be you don't or like
molecule man you make em look cool you
make it look better than they normally
looks in the comics and you kind of
basically start pitting all of these
heroes and different variant versions of
our characters against each other
cat versus calf like in this movie but
on a grander scale as big as the final
battle in this movie I would lose it and
also the Russos have said if we were to
come back that's the movie we want to
make is secret Wars I like how you save
yourself I feel like you guys covered it
covered what will probably happen but
one thing I want to kind of point out
for when I feel like it I don't know it
just stood out to me when I was watching
the movie so maybe you guys kind of
notice it too when rocket is talking
about what the gauntlet what the snap
did I in in the moment on earth he says
that I there was a cosmic event
essentially on earth that released this
unimaginable amount of energy and I was
like well there are your mutants right
that's how you make make mutants so are
the x-men about to happen I hope not
yeah yeah we did time I think we kind of
fit like
off screen we were kind of talking about
fantastic for being a more exciting
prospect but like before we got x-men
like it like the idea of you wanting
someone maybe that I guess an
intelligent person or scientist that
could kind of step in for like Tony
Stark would be kind of interesting to
you you read Richards you want your hot
head you want your big misunderstood guy
you hope to get the thing and you gets
to storm you need to round out deal the
Marvel Illuminati right and it's like
Professor X has cooled off with the
problems with x-men it's so heavy you
can't introduce x-men without
introducing the fact that they are based
around a metaphor for racism in the
sixties like that is a heavy topic to
play with in a Marvel movie like
Fantastic Four could just be this plucky
family that is like we like going on
adventures and this guy's better rocks
like that's what we need we need to have
another super genius like a Reed
Richards you need to have that family
dynamic we don't have it right now and
if there is a group or a franchise that
screams Disney it is the Fantastic or a
million percent it's so good like we
need it I mean we do need it I just
haven't had like a really solid
adaptation of the fantastic forums
fan for stick yeah it's we need we need
to show people who aren't comic readers
that the Fantastic Four are actually
really cool interesting characters
whereas people already kind of know
x-men people are like excited they liked
the Hugh Jackman depiction there's a lot
of those movies that worked really well
if you've already kind of trust it so
they'll come back around to it and
thanks 5 when [ __ ] comes back to it we
need to like show to the world we need
to reintroduce Fantastic Four this and
also it's like with Disney pitch like oh
it's live-action Incredibles and then
there you go like that's exactly what
wasn't what they want from then so yeah
super onboard yeah okay it's a fine know
x-men how about Namor and here's here's
why I asked that and not because I'm
pitching it did did you guys and same
thing for you guys did it ring weird for
any of you when they started talking
about an earthquake under the sea after
that stuff now like just because they
keep doing those things like that this
thing happened they've been doing it in
movies for comic book movies since the
beginning of comic book where it is
almost like a nod do you think that
actually this movie though where they
they had like there were moments in this
movie where I could tell they edited
someone like walking like they just got
over there really fast because it was
such I had to be such a type movie yeah
to give a line about what Condon's put
ignoring an earthquake under the sea and
it's potentially setting up for this
battle between Wakanda and Atlantis and
in my opinion or do you guys think it's
just fanservice
I thought it was a adapted from the
Infinity Gauntlet comics where wasn't
there there was a huge tsunami that like
threatened the eastern seaboard I
thought it was a reference to that like
after the snap happens there's more like
natural disasters that continue to
happen on earth I read it as that but
now that you mentioned it it's like yeah
of course there are no accidents in
Marvel movies everything cost a village
on a map Buchanan's gonna be in a movie
six years later yeah if dr. Stephen
strange gets mentioned as a list of
interested people he's gonna show up
later they move it they did have
O'Connor on that map and yeah yeah I
just feel like in a world where you
already have an Aquaman you're gonna
have 12 more Aquaman's and like three
more movies about like that one scene in
Aquaman like do we really need a name or
like it's such a a parallel to Aquaman
like I feel like Marvel and Disney are
smart enough to be like this is the same
territory we don't need to do this
Kennedy like there's so many other
characters you can do that they're not
being touched by any other franchise
it's weight cuz like name work could be
a bright like you could get to Namor
through Fantastic Four and since he's a
mutant you could kind of connect them to
x-men like there's something there like
so convoluted like you they do the
Russos and other directors do such a
good job it kind of distilling
characters down to what works just for
what they want to say like what their
story is but in such a confusing
character and he on screen he has to be
in his underwear cuz that's what he
wears in every battle every flying
around pointy ears and all eyebrows up
to here now the best question is will
dwindle s'en get an EP credit because he
was technically attached to name Warren
for like 15 years much like he got an EP
credit and Shazam that's the real
question are we gonna get my question is
is they were going to be fat are all the
okay so uh before we wrap up when we're
getting close to wrapping up here I want
to talk just for a second here about
well we'll start with talking about his
cameo and then just what Stanley did
here for us did you did your screening
notice the
man my first time watching it up three
is I think people thought it was Marc
Maron oh hey look at from glow this is
it I know I said first time I didn't
notice a bumper sticker until the second
time what did the bumpers lean upset oh
yeah
yeah I mean what do you guys think he
was thought about all this I mean the
way this all wrapped up I mean he
probably knew right
probably yeah like and also proud like
you ended on the biggest that
blockbuster ending you could possibly
imagine for a movie we couldn't even
picture what this was like again I
didn't see a Pegasus being in this final
battle and my guy like I don't know how
you would have gone more epic than this
and there's no way he wasn't at least a
little bit proud he absolutely was I
mean Stan was a fan of every single
thing that that transpired into becoming
a business right the fact that it was
him and a couple of guys in midtown
Manhattan in the 60s just doodling and
making these dumb characters and the
fact that it's now become this massive
franchise and Mysterio's about to have
action figures based on and an academy
nominated actor like all this stuff is
so insane I think he would have been
insanely proud he was just a huge huge
huge fan of the success of comic book
movies yeah I saw a connection when with
the death of Tony Stark and it's seen
you know like it's okay we're gonna be
okay you brought us all together and
that was a huge victory and
accomplishment so you can let go and I I
kind of felt a connection with Stan Lee
the fact that he was able to bring all
this together create this world and this
idea of like interconnectivity of people
who are so different and being able to
find like a common agenda I felt like
some reverberations thematically before
we go in too much we just want to play a
video that we made about Stan so if we
can go ahead and just go and roll that
video Devin
they're the greatest stories ever told
Eero show us we don't need to be perfect
to do what's right work it's not about
living without fear but facing injustice
it's not about being powerful but
finding your calling when you least
expect it they show us it's okay to be
vulnerable no matter how tough you are
they were characters that reflected my
own heartbreak The Hulk a normal guy
one-minute range of emotions the next
just like me because even though they're
heroes they're still human it's no fun
reading about somebody who's perfect you
want to read about people that you've
been identified with because we've all
got problems and if you can create and
write about a character who is flawed
but manages to overcome those flaws then
I think that's pretty good
my motto is excelsior that's an old word
that means upward and onward to greater
glory keep moving forward and if it's
time to go it's time
nothing lasts forever you know I guess
one person can make the difference
egg cell CR
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much for being here you
guys were awesome but these guys were
awesome give it up for Matt Rob so much
thank you so much to the El Capitan for
hole where the time hearts go to watch
their heroes die hard haha thank you so
much to Himalayan media for helping us
put this together make a plan and for
helping this lobster doctors Plus for
there to be more information about that
but from us to you guys thank you guys
so much you guys are the best for being
here that's that's it for this episode
of new rock stars live we're gonna hang
out with everybody who's actually in
this room though and get to mingle and
talk nerdy thank you to everybody helped
us put this on the thank you guys so
much
[Applause]
[Music]